>> Bill: THANK YOU.
BACK TO YOU THROUGHOUT THE
MORNING.
MORE ON THIS NOW WANT TO BRING
IN FORMER ACTING CUSTOMS AND
BOARD HE PROTECTION
COMMISSIONER MARK MORGAN.
I WANT VIEWERS TO SEE THIS ON
SCREEN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY PROJECTS FOR 2021 THAT
117,000 CROSSINGS COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR AT 33% YOU HAD THE
PANDEMIC THEN.
GOING BACK TO  2019, 80,000.
WHAT’S GOING ON HERE, SIR?
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT.
LISTEN TO YOUR OWN WORDS THAT I
AGREE WITH.
RECORD NUMBERS.
YOU ARE JUST TALKING ABOUT UAC.
I JOTTED DOWN A FEW STATS.
117,000 UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
WE’RE ALSO LOOKING TO PROJECT
AT THIS RATE OF 1.4 MILLION
TOTAL TRYING TO ILLEGALLY ENTER
THIS COUNTRY.
WE’RE LOOKING AT 5,000 A DAVE
THAT WE’RE ENCOUNTERING ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER ILLEGALLY
ENTERING.
400 OF THOSE ARE UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS.
RIGHT NOW WE DON’T TALK ABOUT
THIS RIGHT NOW.
WE’RE LOOKING AT ALMOST 1,000
GOT AWAYS BECAUSE THE BORDERS
AREN’T SECURE.
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR WE LOOK
AT 200,000 GOTAWAYS.
IT IS A CRISIS BUT THIS WEEK
THE SECRETARY OF DHS GOT IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND LIED SAYING IT IS A
CHALLENGE RATHER THAN THE
CRISIS IT IS.
>> Dana: WE WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOUND HERE.
THIS IS THE CASE THERE ARE SOME
DEMOCRATS TRYING TO STOUND THE
ALARM.
MANY AREN’T GOING TO CALL IT A
CRISIS, IT IS A CHALLENGE.
WATCH.
>> THE CRISIS WAS IN 2014.
THE CRISIS WAS IN 2019.
DO WE HAVE A CRISIS RIGHT NOW
THE SNAPSHOT RIGHT NOW?
NO.
ARE WE GETTING THERE?
YES IF WE DON’T MAKE ANY
CHANGES.
>> AT WHAT POINT DOES IT BECOME
A CRISIS?
>> WELL, I WOULD SAY I DON’T
THINK WE NEED TO MEET YOUR BAR
OF WHAT WE NEED TO CALL IT.
WE ARE APPROACHING THIS
HUMANELY.
>> [INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
>> Dana: MAYBE TAKE THE
POLITICS OUT OF IT FOR A SECOND.
WHEN YOU WERE THERE AS AN
OFFICIAL AS CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL WHAT IS YOUR THRESHOLD
LEVEL FOR A CRISIS?
>> I’LL GO BACK TO -- THAT’S A
GREAT QUESTION.
THIS IS NOT A RIGHT OR LEFT
THING.
I’LL GO BACK WHEN I WAS CHIEF
OF THE BORDER PATROL UNDER A
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION,
UNDER THEN SECRETARY JAY
JOHNSON WHO SAID QUOTE, HIS
WORDS, NOT MINE, 1,000 WAS A
BAD DAY.
WHEN I WORKED FOR HIM AS THE
CHIEF, BELIEVE ME, 1,000 WAS A
BAD DAY.
IF YOU GO BACK TO 2019 THE SAME
DEMOCRATS INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVE SAID IT WAS A
CRISIS IN 2019.
THE NUMBERS WE’RE SEEING ARE
EXCEEDING THE NUMBERS IN 2019.
THIS IS NOT A RIGHT OR LEFT
THING.
HOW THEY PHRASE IT DEPENDS ON
WHICH SIDE OF THE AISLE YOU
STAND ON RIGHT NOW.
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE BETTER,
DANA.
>> Bill: A GREAT QUESTION.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE TOLD THAT
A NUMBER OF MIGRANT KIDS ON
PACE TO EXCEED -- KIDS JUST NOW.
YOU TALK ABOUT UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR TO EXCEED THE ALL-TIME
RECORD BY 45%.
HOW DO YOU STOP THAT?
HOW DO YOU SLOW IT DOWN?
AND IF YOU DON’T, WHAT IS THE
SHORT TERM RESOLUTION?
>> BILL, IT IS ALMOST TOO LATE.
LOOK, THIS ADMINISTRATION
WITHIN 30 DAYS HAS -- BECAUSE
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
ABSOLUTELY DISMANTLED AND
DESTROYED EVERY EFFECTIVE
POLICY THAT HAD REDUCED THE
FLOW.
LIKE YOU SAID THIS TIME LAST
YEAR IT IS OVER 100% INCREASE
IN MINORS ALONE.
IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
CRUELTY, LOOK, THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW, BILL, IS ACTUALLY
ENCOURAGING AND FACILITATING
AND INCENTIVIZING MOMS AND DADS
IN COUNTRIES IN WESTERN
HEMISPHERE TO HAND THEIR KIDS
OVER TO CARTELS AND SMUGGLING
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE THE
DANGEROUS TREK DURING THE
MIDDLE OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
TO ILLEGALLY ENTER THIS COUNTRY.
THIS COUNTRY SHOULDN’T BE DOING
THAT.
WE SHOULD BE STOPPING THIS.
WE NEED A.G.s AND GOVERNORS OF
STATES TO STAND UP AND
CHALLENGE THESE ACTIONS IN
COURT.
THAT’S THE ONLY WAY WE’LL BE
ABLE TO HAVE AN IMPACT RIGHT
NOW.
>> Dana: GREAT POINT.
I THINK ABOUT THAT, TOO.
IN TERMS OF THE HUMAN CONDITION
AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
MIGRANTS ARE TEENS, OKAY?
THEY’RE STILL CHILDREN.
AND WHAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
GOING THROUGH.
I KNOW THE WRENCHING DECISION
TO TELL YOUR KID GO FOR IT.
BUT THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE.
IT IS GOING TO COME BACK TO
HURT A LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT WILL BE A MAJOR -- NOT
POLITICAL ISSUE BUT SOMETHING
THAT AMERICA IS GOING TO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH.
WE CANNOT PRETEND IT’S NOT A
PROBLEM.
>> DANA QUICK AND TO YOUR POINT
RIGHT NOW LIKE YOU SAID IT
DOESN’T MATTER.
MAJORITY ARE 15 AND 16 BUT
STILL MINORS, RIGHT?
THEY’RE TAKING THIS DANGEROUS
TREK AND GOING THROUGH COVID
HOT SPOTS IN LARGE GROUPS A
COVID PETRI DISH STUFFED IN
OVERCROWDED UNSANITARY STASH
HOUSES, TRACTOR TRAILERS.
YOU MENTIONED IN YOUR OPENING A
GOOD PORTION ARE TESTING
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
THIS IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
>> Bill: IT IS NOT OKAY.